what do you think about intersex people
competing against women
well you know i've said before that i
think if you start pulling on this
thread about sex and sport that
effectively
sport as we know it is going to
disappear and that that may in fact
this may just be our maturation into
an adult understanding of human
variation
i don't know what to do with intersex
people because you know they are
exceptional and each one but the very
nature of intersex is that each one
is a one-off phenomenon right you know
i'm sympathetic
to uh
these people have as much right to live
and participate as anyone but there's no
obviously natural way given the binary
nature of sex to
integrate them into sex that is divided
by those categories
yeah um so it may be that that's
bad but that we have to in order to
preserve
um sex divided sports
that we have to just accept that there
is nothing to be done in that case
yeah it may be and yet on this question
it's a much it's a much murkier question
than the question
of uh trans people playing against
uh people of the gender that they now
identify with as opposed to of the sex
that they are born to
that that is not a murky question
whereas intersex is
uh in part because intersex can look a
lot of different ways
and um and maybe just that
let me ask you this what about the
following rubric yeah
um an intersex person if they want to
compete in men's sports
certainly can there's no reason to bar
anyone
i think from men's sports if they want
to try to compete there well i've
actually i've seen
i've seen an argument i've said
something i guess i didn't say intersex
but i i said you know
trans men want to compete against men
fine trans women against women
um not so much and and i have heard
pushback that made me think
that for some sports for something like
wrestling yep
actually um you know akin
to actually one woman soldier in
you know at war is really going to
change the dynamics of everything and
this this is
it's a difficult thing you know like
what what is the answer
how you know what what should you allow
and you know maybe
you know a trans man wrestling against a
bunch of other men
is going to throw those men in some way
that has nothing to do with sport but
has to do with
us being sexual beings um that may may
render that not fair and not sportsmen
like
okay so let's uh upgrade the rubric okay
the rubric is
for most sports anybody who wants to
compete
in the men's division is
free to try out some sports are
exceptional
contact sports contact sports let's say
and
uh those who want to compete who are
intersex and want to compete
in uh women's sports
would have to be evaluated by some
criteria that suggested that it was
actually inappropriate that you know
that they're
the female nature of their physiology
but that criteria is exactly the point
where it's
it's muddy right so yes yes to
everything you said accepted exactly
that criteria which is
well but suppose that what you did was
you set a standard that ensured that
this just did not disadvantage
uh i don't know what the terminology
would be
women with an uncomplicated um
needle-borne women yeah natal board the
problem is i'm stumbling over this
because i
believe that the nature of intersex is
such that there are
people in that category who are
essentially
like native-born women yeah no and this
is i mean as much as
as much as ann fausto sterling
contributed you know helped create this
this complete chaos we're living in
right now
um as i understand it her maybe even
slightly
spoofing original formulation of like
there's men
and there's women and there's what she
was calling hermaphrodites which is what
we call
intersex organisms that aren't people
and she was using that word
um for people and then she said and
there's
female-like hermaphrodites and there's
male like appetites thus getting us to
the five sexes which of course is not
true there's two sexes right
but you know the the the actually like
really you know completely equally male
and female intersex person
is the rarity yeah and the different
kinds of developmental
mistakes that happen that end up
rendering a person intersex
might leave you much more male or much
more female right
right and in fact what i'm alluding to
though is
my understanding and you tell me if you
think i've got it wrong but
that some people who are intersex
wouldn't know
that they were intersex right but for
let's say a karyotype a chromosomal test
and my sense is such a person probably
is perfectly fine and in fact totally
appropriate to be
competing in you know sport on whichever
side
of that boundary depending right like if
you know if you
if you appear female and you're raised
female and and you grew up female you
believe yourself to be female but you
have undescended testicles that are
producing testosterone at levels
uh that are higher than you know other
natal women
and they have been throughout your
developmental period as well
you know that that that is a tricky
situation
right that is a tricky situation on the
other hand let's say
that you are xy female
where your sry gene is defective
that seems less tricky frankly right
it's not tricky because effectively
you're female in every regard but two
right a technical chromosomal issue and
a fertility issue
exactly and those yeah those reasons uh
those
those rather those ways in which you are
not female
have not affected your development your
anatomy your physiology your brain
any of that so far as we know but they
really seem not to right
right and so my interest is when
somebody
is effectively female and then there is
a technical exception to that i don't
want to see them denied access to
anything and i don't think it's
necessary to protect anybody else's
rights
so i would love to see that covered but
the problem is
there is a vast gray area in which yeah
right
i mean this is part of the and i feel
like some of it is intentional confusion
by the trans rights people it's like ah
it's not just the chromosomes like know
what like
no one who thinks about this carefully
thought it was the chromosomes at all
the fact is that mammals like birds like
some other clades
have chromosomal sex determination but
that is quite different from saying that
it's the chromosomes
that are fundamental to being male or
female male and female pre-exists
chromos sex chromosomes
uh by 100 million years or more yeah i
disagree with you that
people don't believe this though i think
that which wait don't
what did i what do you think i said what
i think you said is that nobody who
thinks about this deeply
thinks that the chromosomes are
essential and i think there are lots of
people who think about it deeply but
don't think
evolutionarily deeply and therefore
don't know that the
relationship between maleness and
femaleness is not fundamentally about
chromosomes their senses so yeah it's
easy to find
phds in biology who think it's all about
the chromosomes and that's why we have
such
you know bafflingly naive but um
seemingly confused
experts um you know actually confused
but naive conversations in which
everyone's got their their phd that they
can trot out and say well
you know an xy female must you know
proves that the sex isn't binary
no it doesn't it does no such thing
right which is why the rubric that
um you've been advocating
for is so important which is that this
is actually about gamete size and that
is
unambiguous it's you know we have two
size gametes and
that's just gametes so you know sessile
and large or zippy and small
you know cytoplasm rich cytoplasm poor
[Music]
right